there's something called the kardashev
scale it's a method of measuring
civilization's level of technological
advancement based on the amount of
energy it's able to use so type 1
civilization and this might be given all
your work is not no longer a scale that
makes quite make sense but it very much
focuses on the source of fusion natural
source of fusion which is for us the Sun
and type 1 civilizations are able to
Leverage
uh sort of collect all the energy that
hits Earth and then type two
civilizations are the ones that are able
to Leverage
the entirety of the energy that comes
from the Sun by maybe building something
but yeah yeah so when will we reach type
1 status is get to the level which were
I think maybe a few orders of magnitude
away from currently and in general do
you think about this kind of stuff
because where energy is so fundamental
to this like of life on Earth but also
the expansion of life into the universe
oh yeah so what one of the fun you know
on the on a weekend one I I sat down and
figured out what would it mean for
Interstellar travel like to have a DT
Fusion in fact one of the I talked about
my design class one of my design classes
was how you use
um essentially a special configuration
of a fusion device for not only
traveling to but colonizing Mars so
because what would you talk about energy
use being at the heart of civilizations
like so what if you want to go to Mars
not to just visit it but actually like
leave people there and make it something
happen it needs massive amounts of
energy so what would that look like and
it actually transforms what how you're
thinking about doing that as well too oh
yeah so we we do all those kinds of fun
and actually it was a fairly you know
quasi-realistic actually so do you think
it'll be nuclear fusion that powers the
civilization on Mars well what we
considered was something so it turns out
that there's thorium
which is a heavy element so it's a
so-called fertile element that we know
we still know fairly little about the
the geology of Mars and and in the Deep
sense and we know that there's a lot of
this on the surface of Mars so one of
the things we considered was what would
happen that it's basically a combination
of a fusion device that actually makes
fuel from the thorium
oh but the under but the underlying
energy one was was Fusion itself as well
too so this is one of the examples of
being trying to be clever right around
those things or what is it you know this
also means it's like an Interstellar
travel it's like oh yeah that looks
almost like impossible basically from an
energy balance point of view it's just
because like the energy required to that
you have to transport to get there
almost the only things that would work
are DT fusion and basically um
Annihilation It's like Star Trek right
your sense is that Interstellar travel
will require fusion power oh it's it's
almost even impossible with fusion power
actually it's so hard
it's so hard because you have to carry
the fuel with you and the rocket
equation tells you about how much fuel
you use to take so what you end up with
is like how long does it take to go to
these places and it's like staggering
you know periods of time so I I tend to
believe that there is alien
civilizations dispersed all throughout
yeah but we might have totally isolated
from them so you think we're not there's
none in this galaxy
so like and I guess and the question I
also have is what kind of do you think
they have nuclear fusion I was like is
it all yes the physics all the same yeah
oh the physics is all the same yeah
right so this is the and this is the
Fermi Paradox like where where the hell
is everybody in the universe right
um well there's some so you know the
scariest one of those is that I would
point out that there's been you know
there's you know order of many tens of
millions of species on the planet Earth
and only one ever got to the point of
sophisticated tool use that we could
actually start essentially leveraging
the power of what what's in nature to
our own will does this mean that
basically this means so almost look
there is almost certainly life or DNA
equivalence or whatever would be
somewhere I mean just because you just
need to soup and you need energy and you
get Organics and whatever the equivalent
of amino acids are but you know most of
life on Earth has been that those are
still amazing but it's still it's not
very interesting are we are we actually
the accident of History this is a very
interesting one they're super rare super
rare and then of course the other part
is that also just the other scary part
of it which is if you look at the fairy
paradoxes good good we got to this point
how long has it been in humans so humans
Homo Sapien has been around for whatever
100 000 years 200 000 years something
our ability in in that timeline to
actually make an imprint on the universe
like for by emitting radio waves or by
modifying you know in nature in a
significant way has only been for about
a hundred of those hundred thousand
years
and you know are we this is a good
question so is it by definition that by
the fact that when you are able to reach
that level of being able to manipulate
nature and for example discover you know
discover like fission or or or other or
or burning fossil fuels and all this is
that what it says oh you're doomed
because by definition any species that
gets to that point that can modify their
environment like that they'll actually
push themselves you know past that's
that's one of the most depressing
scenarios that I can imagine yeah so the
the so basically we will never line up
in time because you get this little
teeny window in time over civilization
might occur and you you can never see it
because you never these these sort of
like scatter like like fireflies around
the Galaxy and you never yeah yeah and
then explodes it destroys itself because
of the and when we say destroy ourselves
all I would have to do is that we
basically go if you humans are all left
and we're still living on the planet and
but all we have to do is go to the
technology of like you know 1800 yeah
and we're invisible in the universe
again
yeah he so it was when I when I listened
to the point I I thought I wanted to
talk about this as well too because this
it comes from well it comes from a
science point of view actually of what
it means but also to me it's like
another compelling driver of telling us
it's like why we should try really hard
not to screw this up like we're in this
unique place of our ability to discover
and to make it and I just don't want to
give up about thinking that we can get
through yeah I tend to see that there is
some kind of game theoretic Force like
with Demetrius shared destruction that
ultimately in each human being there's a
desire to survive and a willingness to
cooperate yeah to have compassion for
each other in order to survive and I
think that I mean maybe not in humans
but I can imagine nearly infinite number
of species in which
that overpowers
any uh technological advancement that
can destroy or rewind the species so I
think if humans fail
I hope they don't
I see a lot of evidence for them not but
it seems like somebody will survive and
there you start to ask questions about
why why we haven't met yet maybe it's
just space is large oh spaces it's I I
think in logarithms and I can't even
fathom you know space this is
extraordinary right yeah it's
extraordinarily large yeah I mean
there's so many places on Earth I just
recently visited Paris for the first
time yeah and there's so many other
places I haven't visited there's so many
other places well I like to you know
it's interesting that we have this
fascination with alien life we have what
is essentially alien life on Earth
already like you think about the
organisms that develop around deep sea
like thermal vents one of my favorite
books of all time from Stephen J Gould
if you've never read that book it kind
of blows your mind it's about the
Cambrian explosion of life and it's like
oh you look at these things and it's
like our the chance of us existing as a
species like the the genetic diverse
city was larger back then you know this
is about five about 500 million years
ago or something like that it is a
mind-altering trip of thinking about our
place in the universe I have to say plus
the Mind itself yeah is the kind of
alien but almost
um
almost a mystery to ourselves we still
don't understand it the very the very
mechanism that helps us explore the
world is still a mystery yeah so that
like understanding that will also unlock
um a quite quite possibly unlock our
ability to understand the world and
maybe build machines that help us
entertain the world build tools then I
mean it already has I mean our ability
to understand the world is is ridiculous
almost Ashley
[Laughter]